bien le retour du pacs après le fiasco
de la première discussion les députés
ont retrouvé un texte légèrement modifié
dans la majorité on a resserré les rangs
l'opposition en fait elle une affaire de
principe et elle a déposé plusieurs
centaines d'amendements à l'assemblée ce
soir valérie patton marc felix loin de
l'atmosphère passionné il y a trois
semaines christine boutin le premier
orateur de l'opposition a lancé son
réquisitoire contre le pacs un
discours-fleuve répétitif de quatre
heures devant un hémicycle bien garni
applaudissements de la droite quolibets
de la gauche
la députée udf accuse la majorité
plurielle d'ouvrir une brèche dans
l'institution du mariage et de la
famille
une fois qu'on sera pacsés
si on est un couple hétérosexuel on
pourra pas refuser l'adoption on ne voit
pas pourquoi les pacsés homosexuels ne
pourrait pas puisqu'ils sont dans le
même moule juridique ne pourrait pas
avoir l'adoption c'est l'enjeu qu'est ce
que c'est que ces mascarades ses
contorsions ces danses du ventre de la
gauche une gauche qui s'attendaient à
cette bataille frontale et sans merci
annoncé par la droite en fin de journée
le garde des sceaux s'est chargé de
défendre l'engagement du gouvernement
le pacs ne change rien au droit actuel
de la famille car la seule cohabitation
de deux individus pacte ou non ne fait
pas une famille c'est donc
volontairement que le pacs est sans
effet sur les règles de la filiation de
l'autorité parentale et sur les droits
de l'enfant
certes les communistes et les verts
contestent l'extension du pacs aux
frères et soeurs mais il devrait voter
le texte comme un seul homme
toutefois pour préserver la sérénité des
débats le gouvernement est prêt à
attendre la fin du mois de novembre pour
faire voter ce pacs deuxième version de
quoi peut-être amadouer les plus modérés
de l'opposition qui savent déjà que les
jeux sont faits